KARTHIK BALAKRISHNAN:
Hello, everyone.
In this video, we
plan to talk about how
to use Google Cloud to
build infrastructure
for your website that is
scalable, highly available,
and widely distributed.
Today's presentation
has two parts.
The first provides a
high level overview
of what infrastructure
pieces are involved
and how they fit
with each other.
As a brief introduction, I'm
Karthik, a product manager
within Google Cloud.
The second part walks
you through the details
of how to use gcloud to actually
build the infrastructure
end to end and will be covered
by my colleague Arman Rye.
While there are many
options available,
the key insight we want
to drive is to showcase
how Google Cloud can be used
as a one-stop shop for building
scalable, highly
available websites that
can be distributed all across
the globe with relatively
low effort.
Here are the products that
we will cover in this video.
Let's start at the
very beginning,
buying and registering a domain.
Until now, this process
was outside Google Cloud.
And it was not very
straightforward
to buy, register,
verify the ownership,
and set up DNS records
so that your customers
can reach your website.
We have recently
launched Google Domains
that is integrated
into Google Cloud
to offer a more
seamless workflow
and to manage your
domain's lifecycle.
Cloud Domains
allows you to check
for availability of the
domain name and purchase it.
It will also
register this domain
and verify the
ownership, Finally,
it supports API so you
can programmatically
manage your domain portfolio.
Once domain has been
registered, the next step
is to create DNS records
so your customers can
visit your website.
Cloud DNS offers public DNS
zone setter accessible worldwide
and has high availability
and scalability.
We will create a public DNS
zone for the new domain you just
registered in this step.
Cloud DNS also supports DNSSEC.
And enabling it is very easy.
DNSSEC is used to defend
against techniques
that hackers use
to direct computers
to rogue websites and servers.
We will need to add
DNS records to the zone
before it's reachable
by you customers.
But we will do that
in a different step.
As next steps, we will
create the back ends.
This represents the actual web
server that runs your website.
We will split this
into two parts.
Use managed instance group
for serving your website.
This represents compute
virtual machines
that process incoming
requests and identify
what actions to take.
We use managed instance
groups primarily because you
can control them
as a single entity
and because it is
easy to scale when
the demand for your
website increases, say,
during a holiday season.
Managed instance groups
work by using a template
that you create.
The template defines machine
type, boot disk image,
or container image and
other instance properties.
Once created, you can either
create individual VMs or groups
of VMs and control them
as a single entity.
You can manually set the
size of the number of VMs
or use autoscaling if
your website is stateless.
The managed instance
group automatic updater
also lets you safely deploy
new versions of software
to your MIG and supports
a flexible range
of rollout scenarios,
such as rolling updates
and Canary updates.
You can control the speed
and scope of deployment
as well as the level of
disruption to your service.
Finally, you can deploy this
in multiple GCP regions,
increasing your fault
tolerance and availability.
Next, we use Cloud Storage for
static content like images,
backgrounds, videos, and
other portions of the website
that don't change frequently.
Cloud Storage allows you to
store large quantities of data
that can be accessed worldwide.
More importantly, it
offers high availability
with multiple
redundancy options.
It also makes it easy to ingest
your media content on the one
end and makes it easy
to distribute over
a content delivery network like
Cloud CDN or another provider.
After creating
back ends, we will
create the front
end that will handle
the traffic to your website.
Google Cloud HTTPS
load balancing
is a global proxy-based
layer 7 load balancer
that enables you
to run and scale
your services worldwide behind
a single external IP address.
It does much better than
DNS-based load balancing
because there are
no TTLs involved
and the load
balancer can respond
much quicker to changes
in traffic patterns
or health of the packets.
It also allows you to do
content-based load balancing
using URL maps to select the
appropriate back end service.
Finally, you can run within
Google's premium tier
networking that will offer
cross-regional load balancing
and allowing you
to direct traffic
to the closest healthy
back end that has capacity.
Now it's time to add some
security by adding Cloud
Armor to the incoming traffic.
Cloud Armor sits
at the Google edge
and provides DDoS protection,
along with predefined rules
that defend against cross-site
scripting and SQL injection
attacks.
You can also create custom
IP-based allow- and deny-lists
and prevent malicious users
from consuming your resources.
Here's an overall
picture that shows
how everything is put together.
With that, I hand
it over to Arman,
who will go over the same steps
but in much greater detail.
ARMAN RYE: Thanks, Karthik.
My name is Arman Rye.
And I am a network
specialist at Google Cloud.
For this portion of
the presentation,
I will walk you through
an example deployment
on Google Cloud from
start to finish.
We will go from
ordering a domain
all the way through
verifying that all
the appropriate
features are enabled.
Let's get started.
We will begin our demo with the
domain registration process.
The first step is to check
that the domain you would
like to purchase is available.
Running the
search-domains command
will give you a list of TLDs
and the associated prices.
Even though we have specified
a .com in the search,
the result will give many
TLDs that are available
for purchase.
Once you have
decided on the domain
name you would like to purchase
and confirmed it is available,
you need to create a Cloud
DNS zone with the domain name.
This zone is where you will
manage DNS for this domain.
Make sure you set
the DNSSEC state
to on to utilize the
security benefits of DNSSEC.
Next, you will actually
need to order the domain.
The gcloud response from
the registrar command
will prompt you to add
information about your business
and list a point of contact.
The final step is
to link the DNS zone
that we created in step one to
the domain in Cloud Domains.
This will ensure that the
appropriate name server
records, as well as the
appropriate DS records,
are added for DNSSEC.
A great feature of
the GCP platform
is that this step is
automated for you.
So you don't need
to do it yourself.
We strongly encourage customers
to use GCP for both their DNS
and registrar needs due to these
increasing product synergies.
In this demo, we
will be configuring
to back ends, one
for static content
like images, logos, or
videos; and the other
for dynamic content, like
HTML and any APIs your website
relies on.
Let's start with
the static content.
First, we create
a storage bucket.
For this bucket, we have
chosen to have it be regional
in our us-east1 location and to
use the STANDARD storage class.
Second, we must add some
content to the storage bucket.
In a typical
deployment, there are
many options on how to upload
content to a storage bucket.
Please see our documentation
for further information
about how to do so.
Third, we will update the
bucket permissions to public
so that anyone can access
the contents stored.
You can additionally
leverage IAM permissions
if you would like to restrict
access to the bucket.
But we will not be
covering that in this demo.
Now that we have set up our
static content storage bucket,
we will pivot to
dynamic traffic.
Before we can create a
managed instance group,
we must create a template, which
will be the blueprint for all
of the compute we will utilize.
There's a lot of metadata
you can add in this template.
In this example, we
have picked a region
for the compute to
be deployed, a VPC
network that my
networking is utilizing,
as well as a
specific subnet which
I want my compute
instances to utilize.
We have additionally
specified an image
for the compute and a
simple startup script
to install Apache and
run a basic web server.
Now that we've
created the template
for our dynamic
traffic to use, we
need to instantiate the
actual instance group.
The first command creates
the instance group using
the template we just created.
The second command specifies
that we are running our web
application on port 80.
In this demo, we are using HTTP
for the back end of our load
balancer since all traffic is
on Google's private network.
If you'd like, you can
additionally run HTTPS traffic
on port 443 for your back ends.
Before we get into
creating the load balancer,
I want to spend a few
moments discussing
what are the
different components
from a gcloud perspective
that are required.
Starting from the
left in this diagram,
we need a globally
accessible static IP address.
This is the IP address that will
correspond to our load balancer
and is linked using
a forwarding rule.
Second, we have the
actual proxy itself.
We need to create two proxies,
one for HTTP and one for HTTPS.
The global HTTP load balancer
is a proxy load balancer.
So this step is required.
Third, we need to
input some logic that
defines how traffic is routed
between our dynamic back ends
and our static back ends.
This configuration is
called the URL map.
Finally, we need to
identify the different back
ends that we want the
traffic to be sent to,
one for our static bucket and
one for our instance group.
In addition, we
need to configure
whether we'd like to use
Cloud CDN for content caching
or Cloud Armor for security.
There are two steps we need
to take before we start
configuring the load balancer.
We need to reserve a static IP
address for our load balancer
to use.
A common mistake in this step is
not to specify the global flag.
Once we have
reserved it, we need
to list it please save
this IP address for later
in the demonstration.
It's worth mentioning that,
as long as this IP address is
in your static IP
addresses, this IP
will be able to be
utilized by your resources
in your GCP project.
Additionally, we need to
make sure that the firewall
in our VPC is set to allow
traffic from the /16 and /22
[INAUDIBLE] ranges listed.
If you do not do this step your
health checks will be blocked
and no traffic will be able
to reach your back end.
Now we can get started with
configuring our load balancer.
In this first command, we
create a basic health check,
which will probe our
back end on port 80.
This command utilizes
the default settings.
Know that there are a
lot of customizations
available beyond the
defaults for health checks.
But we will not be covering
them in this session.
Health checks are a
very powerful tool
which allow for only
healthy back ends
to receive end user traffic.
The second command
creates a back end service
which we will attach
to our back ends too.
You need to attach a health
check to the back end service.
Once we have created
our back end service,
we need to add the
back ends to it.
The first command adds our
dynamic back end service
to the back end.
The second command
creates a back end bucket
for our static content.
Additionally, we are
including the enable-cdn flag
in our request.
By turning on the
CDN, we are ensuring
that static content
is served globally
from Google's edge
caches instead of direct
from the bucket every time.
By doing so, we are
greatly increasing
the speed of the website.
Cloud CDN by default will
cache static file types.
Google determines file type
by looking at the MIME type
of the response from origin.
We then mapped the MIME type
to a list of static content
mappings that we maintain.
If you do not want to utilize
this method for cache control,
no problem, you can set your
own cache control headers
at origin.
Or you can configure a
force cache all setting.
Be careful when
setting the force cache
all setting because
you may inadvertently
end up caching content that
is intended to be dynamic,
i.e. non-cachable.
The third command here adds
a custom response header
to requests for this back end.
The custom response header
indicates whether or not
the request was served
from the CDN cache.
There are a lot of
other custom headers
that can be added in
addition to the cache status.
You can additionally
add your own headers
and set them to be
whatever you'd like.
Once the back ends are created,
we need to create a URL map.
The URL map is a
construct that is
used to determine traffic
routing between our back ends.
The first command creates
the URL map object.
In this command,
we are specifying
that the default location
for traffic to be sent to
is our dynamic back end.
The second command adds the
logic that any traffic destined
to the path or directory
/images/* should instead be
sent to the back end bucket.
You can add many
different paths here.
But, for our demo, we're
just going to use one.
Additionally, it's
worth mentioning
that there are many more
advanced routing capabilities
available to you beyond path
matching in the global HTTPS
load balancer.
The full list of attributes that
you can route on in the URL map
is listed in our documentation,
as well as guidance
on how to deploy this.
In this section, we
will create the proxies
and order an SSL certificate
to be served at our edge.
The SSL certificate will be
issued by Google certificate
authority or Let's Encrypt.
There are a lot
of customizations
available within SSL GCP.
You can specify, for
example, which TLS versions
you would like to
support or what
cipher suites you would like
clients to support as well.
In this example, we're going
to stick with the defaults.
The first command
creates the HTTP proxy.
This is linked to
the URL map which we
created in the previous step.
The second command orders
an SSL certificate.
There are no
validation records we
need to add since we
are using Cloud DNS.
And, later, we
will point traffic
to the static IP assigned
to this load balancer.
The SSL certificate will take
a few minutes to provision,
but it will be
done automatically.
We need to make sure,
however, that we specify
all of the host names
that we want listed here
in the certificate.
Even while the SSL
certificate is provisioning,
we can use this SSL
certificate to attach
to our HTTPS proxy,
which is what
we are doing in step three.
The last step of
the load balancer
is to attach the static IP
to the HTTP and HTTP proxies.
Step one attaches the
IP to the HTTP proxy.
And step two attaches the
IP to the HTTPS proxy.
By doing this, the IP address,
which is announced globally
will be accessible from
the internet on both ports
80 and 443.
We aren't covering
it in this demo,
but you can do an HTTP-to-HTTPS
redirect in the load balancer.
You can also set
HSTS response headers
if you would like all future
requests by the same client
to use HTTPS no matter what.
One of the last
steps in our demo
is to create a Google
Cloud Armor policy.
Cloud Armor is Google's DDoS
and web application firewall
solution.
Before we configure it,
I want to quickly explain
how Cloud Armor works and
how it is provisioned.
Cloud Armor,
similar to Cloud CDN
is available as part of the
global HTTPS load balancer.
Cloud Armor consists
of security policies.
A security policy is
a collection of rules.
Rules can be custom firewall
rules or particular protections
included in the OWASP top 10.
A Cloud Armor rule has a
priority associated with it.
Similar to the VPC firewall,
the lower the priority number,
the higher up in the match
hierarchy a given rule is.
A security policy is attached
to a back-end service.
A back-end service can only
have one security policy
associated with it.
A security policy can
be reused, however,
across multiple
back-end services.
To configure Cloud
Armor, we must first
create a security policy.
The security policy
will contain the rules
that are applied to our
dynamic content back end.
Once the security
policy has been created,
we can then create
an example rule.
The example rule I
created will block
any traffic that
contains the HTTP request
header called evil-header.
I have also specified
that I would
like to respond to this traffic
with a 403 response code.
This custom rule utilizes the
Common Expression Language,
or CEL.
This is an open-source language
designed for simplicity,
speed, safety, and portability.
I want to take this moment
to additionally highlight
that there is an implicit
rule in Cloud Armor security
policies which dictates whether
traffic is allowed or blocked
by default for that
security policy.
If we do not specify this
flag in the first command,
it will default to
an allow setting.
This translates to
any traffic that
does not match any of
the rules we can figure
will be let through.
Now that we have a security
policy and an example rule,
the remaining step is to
apply it to a back end.
The second step here
is an optional one
but a recommended step.
It enables Cloud Armor's
adaptive protection feature.
Adaptive protection builds
machine learning models
which detect an alert on
anomalous application-level
activity.
It additionally
generates a signature
describing the attack, as well
as generates a custom Google
WAF rule to block the
detected signature.
Adaptive protection is
in public preview as
of the time of this recording.
It's worth mentioning
as well that the custom
rule that that adaptive
protection generates
is not automatically applied.
There is an alerting mechanism.
And you as the user can
decide whether or not
you want to deploy this
rule for your back end.
Now that everything is
set up, the only task
we have left to do is
to point DNS to the IP
we reserved for
our load balancer.
Earlier in the
presentation, we highlighted
how to reserve and obtain
this static IP address.
If you didn't get a
chance to write it down,
you can always go back
and re-list your static IP
addresses for your project.
The DNS gcloud
integration utilizes
a concept called a transaction.
To add any new records, you
must begin a transaction.
You can see this
command in step one
where we start a
transaction for our zone.
Once the transaction
has begun, you
need to specify the records
you would like to add.
In this example, since we
are only adding two records,
I've explicitly listed
them individually.
If you have many records,
you can upload your records
using a BIND file.
For this demonstration,
we will be
adding a www record and
an apex record pointing
to the static IP address
we configured earlier.
Now that we have
added the records,
we can complete our transaction.
Once the transaction
completes, the change
then propagates to
our edge and traffic
will be suitable for the
www and apex domains.
We have completed the
setup for our demo.
Now, for a final few checks.
We can make sure that
everything is functioning
as it is supposed to.
The first check is
perhaps the most obvious.
I'm able to access the image we
uploaded to our storage bucket
at the URL listed,
www.gcpwebdemo.c
om/images/snowboarding.JPG.
This website is
accessible over HTTPS.
I've included a screenshot of
the certificate information
from my browser.
No warnings are prompted,
and the correct common name
is listed.
The certificate is valid
and has not expired.
Additionally, you could
see that the organization
is Google Trust Services for
this particular certificate.
Next, we will verify
that Cloud CDN is running
and that static content is
being cached at Google's edge
as we expected it to.
I've sent a curl to an image in
the storage bucket we created,
the snowboarding.JPG.
In the response, I can
see the custom response
header we added,
gcp-cache-status,
with the value hit.
This means that the response
was served from a GCP edge cache
and not from the
bucket directly.
By using Cloud CDN, you're
able to improve origin offload
and reduce egress costs while
simultaneously increasing
the response speed
for the end user.
To test that Cloud
Armor is working,
we can send a curl request,
including the header name
evil-header.
We configured the Cloud
Armor security policy
with a rule that
explicitly blocks traffic
with this header.
The response from the
curl is a 403 forbidden,
which is exactly
what we expected
and consistent with
what was configured.
Thank you for listening to
this presentation and demo.
We hope you found it useful.
Please add your questions to
the comments if you have any.
Thanks.